government officials can't answer this
Naval Pilot's question with current data
they can deduce just a few things about
this mystery dot based off of how high
it is off the water and how fast it's
likely going it's probably drifting on
the wind and it's brighter than the
ocean it's floating above so it's likely
colder than the water and not using a
propulsion system so it's probably not a
spaceship but because data is so limited
it makes this a UAP an unidentified
anomalous phenomena identifying UAP is
so important because it it's a matter of
National Security it's a matter of
Aviation and safety and it's incredibly
important that we're curious about our
world around us here's why these objects
are so hard to identify and how a new
report from NASA could help solve some
of these Mysteries
Ryan Graves is a former Naval F-18 pilot
who has been an advocate for researching
unidentified anomalous phenomena or uaps
after witnessing one himself that was
very surreal to to see that because we
immediately thought it was a radar error
but it's almost more unsettling when the
thing you thought was an error turned
out to be reality a new report from an
independent study team appointed by NASA
is trying to make it easier to identify
some of these objects but the current
data available makes it a challenge
lack of data was a problem in
identifying this UAP in the Middle East
while we are still looking at it I don't
have any more data other than that one
problem is the quality of images right
now many are taken from military
aircrafts it's often you know grainy
footage where it's kind of hard to tell
and it's like Split Second objects small
spherical object that might go across
the video extremely fast for example
look at this one from South Asia
officials determined that this is likely
just a commercial aircraft but
compression on the video creates trails
around it and the quality makes it hard
to discern what it is
but it's difficult to get higher quality
footage Advanced Radars like those from
NOAA and NASA aren't currently watching
for these objects there is not a mission
to go proactively look for these right
now so what's happening is are people
that are operating these tools are
seeing things that they can't explain
they have no way to report it and but
they're starting to now and we're
starting to see that information come in
the all domain anomaly resolution office
or arrow heads up most efforts to
identify uaps right now but doesn't
always have access to the wealth of data
from places like NASA the FAA and
Commercial agencies so this wasn't
something that people were looking to
develop these ways of sharing
information because it wasn't on their
radar but now it is for agencies like
NASA and for the dod and so now they're
trying to work more together so that the
government has a way to look at this
stuff in one central place but one of
the biggest barriers isn't a
technological problem it's a social one
do I believe there's life in a universe
that is so vast
that it's hard for me to comprehend how
big it is
my personal answer is yes talking openly
about uaps or other unidentified objects
hasn't always been the norm just because
of what the perception was in pop
culture about UFOs a lot of people felt
like if they were to come forward and
talk about what they would see it would
hurt them in certain ways speculation
about aliens is often brought up in
conversations about identifying uaps we
need to move into the realm of science
on this and make this a normal everyday
mundane scientific topic that we can
engage in outside of controversy the
NASA appointed team says that none of
the uaps they've identified so far
suggest that they have extraterrestrial
Origins and that should only be a
hypothesis of Last Resort the report
also says that stigma around this topic
has prevented a lot of data from being
reported
the team concluded that NASA's
involvement could help lend credibility
to the issue and reduce stigma the
agency appointed a director of UAP
research a sign of its investment in the
issue they're extremely well respected
they have a great mind trust at Nasa and
they can apply a lot of intellectual
Force to this problem so I think them
coming into the game is it should be
I'll say a big win for transparency and
for a better understanding this issue
foreign